voici cristal véhicules autonomes
développé par transdev et ses
partenaires cette navette fonctionnant à
l'énergie électrique a vocation à
intégrer le transport public
une première expérimentation à route
ouverte devrait débuter à rouen en 2022
avant un déploiement commercial d'ici à
une cinquantaine de personnes
travaillent sur ce projet à satory vous
voyez derrière moi des billards des
radars nous avons des caméras et
derrière il ya un logiciel qui fait la
perception de l'environnement et dessine
des traducteurs en suivant c'est dans ce
contexte que jean baptiste djebbari
ministre délégué en charge des
transports a visité le site de satory
tout un écosystème autour de la mobilité
autonome des activités allant de la
collecte de données au développement
technologique pour permettre le suivi et
la supervision du véhicule autonome nos
comportements sur la route comme piétons
comme conducteurs sont souvent basées
sur le contrat qu'on se donne à chacun
la perception de ce que va faire l'autre
est ce qu'on anticipait évidemment avec
une machine il faut repenser les
protocoles de communication finalement
entre entre l'humain et la machine et
c'est tout ça qui s'observent et si sur
le plan traits cognitifs et c'est très
intéressant d'ailleurs d'avoir fait
l'expérience ramon sur le simulateur
véhicule ce simulateur piétons en plus
des technologies et des compétences
numériques d'autres connaissances sont
nécessaires pour le développement du
véhicule autonome
c'est une partie de l'activité devait d
comme c'est aussi une innovation qui aie
appelle des compétences en matière de
comportement de science cognitive
d'ergonomie car il ya une grande
dimension humaine dans ce domaine de la
multi autonome avec son simulateur
automobile bd comme travaille aussi à
partir de son simulateur pour les
piétons des expérimentations qui permet
d'étudier le comportement face à la
mobilité autonome c'est savoir si les
personnes en comportement différent d'un
traversée de route face un véhicule
autonome où il va y avoir personne
derrière le volant on a pu observer
également que si on utilise des systèmes
interactifs pour donner l'état du
véhicule à savoir des messages simples
genre je circule
je m'arrête je patiente je démarre dans
ces cas là la personne est plus en
confiance et va opérer une faveur
cette route là où alors hésité malgré la
crise sanitaire bd comme a déposé une
quinzaine de projets d'investissements
d'avenir et une quinzaine de projets
européens avec comme objectif
d'accélérer la décarbonisation et la
digitalisation de la mobilité